yeah welcome to this video playing for
horny for for me from this is fun Hong
Kong okay the hong kong hong kong SAR
china funny wasn't really aware that
they have fun no known flag okay yeah
here that's the funny movie for come on
I really don't know it but why not yeah
I think like a black normally takes this
pawn and I had a brief look at this once
for black and I also came to the
conclusion that black black should take
it but then it's of course I'm not easy
at all now come on g5 let's win some
gain some space am with the pawn on mmm
if I capture with the night I'm on f7
but is it a good idea I mean the pawn is
hanging on on h4 take with the pawn on
the night is probably going to h5 come
on flats and let's do this I'm i somehow
if they're feeling better this is the
way to go it's just more active i mean
the the rook is open now and i'm
attacking at seven okay you can nick and
grab the poem on edge for that well what
can you do um ok b5 hmm
yeah of course beef I the same is
relatively normal move in in this kind
of position I was thinking what about D
5 D 5 before she takes c6 takes on c3
and then Bishop c4 attacking f7 is this
completely completely ridiculous maybe
it is yeah but what else to play I
wonder is it may be a 4a 4b form Bishop
c4 it's also not without its points d 5
it takes d5 what a mess now this is fun
come on I'm spending too much time here
of course over there it's fun to to look
at the possibility is my idea is to go
up before Bishop c4 of course and i'm
attacking f7 which is somewhat difficult
to defend yeah okay now Bishop c4 I'm
having a coffee I hope you don't mind
them the noises in the background yeah
this is clear now I take d5 but I can be
condone I to be successes this is the
problem night to be 6 not maybe maybe
this is still I'm still playable to go
here takes c3 takes c6 it's still not
easy to defend at seven
yeah of course I have no idea what's
going on here yeah what a mess was it
what a mess um I've 7s hanging if I take
it king e 7 mm I don't have I don't
think this is to clear this position I
should probably keep the cooing on that
thing I have six now if it takes be too
i take f6 maybe you can play Bishop
before the script could be M could be a
problem and this is sound somewhat
mind-boggling this position yeah maybe
you can just just cover it now but then
I can takes you three with the tempo and
take off 70 min okay it's a blitz game
it's not them it's not the
correspondence game where you can check
everything forward four or five times
yes um Queen F form or what well just
first take up seven minutes let's check
this first
we have form or queen g4 but Queen Queen
c7 as the point I can we probably can
take be too I mean it's a check only I
should have gone to g3 or something yeah
okay this was not really working there's
some way to to get get get an attacker
all of this hi morning yeah I can't play
Quincy three ads not done yes King is
still a bit a bit a bit shaky but
there's no way I'm going to going to
meet him here
yeah look b 3 b 7 c 8 queen [ __ ] if i
have four moves in a row and probably
okay oops okay today wanted to take of
course but it was what's lost anyway
yeah this was probably a bit too dicey i
actually believe that this might be okay
but it's it's probably not objectively
okay I mean mathematically okay but it's
a it's interesting for her blitz game to
try yeah on the computer actually says
that white is clearly better here okay
but not with this move interesting how
it's white clearly better i can take
here of course can take your first I
just thought just King e7 yeah I had I
had a vague suspicion that this might be
actually good for white and it is
because of Bishop a three but I didn't
really see what what what the threat is
in this position maybe I don't need a
very big threat and this doesn't have
any good square Holly if you go here
look at this goodnight f7 was the point
yeah of course you always reluctant to
exchange Queens but may be here this was
the way to go computer wants to go here
but also gives white an ad share in this
position funny enough what is this
material of my seven to six ports got
two pawns him and I've got there of
course I cut this pawn it wants to
continue like this yeah the point is
always that this light it cannot go
anywhere this is just not helping
because of the the fork on f7
interesting so this insane stuff was was
actually an idea funny but the computer
gives this move as is clearly better for
black at first not allow it changes his
mind interesting oops sorry this this
okay yeah I Bishop Bishop to before this
is crazy Bishop before the dep king f1
need to go out of this Bishop 86 and now
King here what cat friend stuff is this
I can take it okay sorry not this I
thought he can take yeah I am take take
and knowledge check yeah this is
completely completely insane in a
computer evaluation is equal great okay
okay it was just a chaotic game that
didn't work out for me alright thanks
for watching I hope you had fun anyway